[Music]
darcy's with us in houston texas hey
darcy how are you
all right how you guys doing today
great how's it going
oh joy
so what's up how can we help
uh well basically i just need some
guidance some uh real guidance and i've
done uh financial peace university a
very very long time ago so
uh
and i
was it i tried it failed it tried it
again failed it kept going back and
forth and now i'm back around to it
again
um i'm now in a position where i have
i'm a disabled vet and i work full time
so i'm receiving money i'm receiving
like two incomes i'm a single parent i'm
trying to basically just
figure out what to do i have a kid
that's going to college in a couple
years and i have nothing i have i have
nothing for him but fortunately because
of it i still have um
he'll be able to go to school in state
for free
um
why did you fail fpu
you said you took it several times why'd
you fail
uh because i couldn't uh i wasn't
working uh when i couldn't um
due to
part of things going on with my
disability or whatever i was unable to
work
what is the nature of your disability
honey
uh it
it was physical
physical and mental
so at one point i wasn't able to work
but now i am working a full-time job and
i'm able to uh and i'm able to do
uh
i'm able to do this day by day
and i also hopefully here hopefully i'm
also looking for another job uh within
the system to pay more money so what do
you make of a disability
uh
disability
it'll be at 40
at 40 000
and what do you make on your other job
i'm a job uh
after taxes and everything it'll be 31.
i just did that how many kids have you
got
two
and how old are they
16 14.
okay
all right you did not fail fpu because
you lost your job
that's not true
you failed fpu because you lost your
focus
and that might be true because of
some of the mental things you're facing
i don't know
um yeah or it could be or it could be it
was more like me i was just lazy
[Laughter]
i don't know you got to decide that i'm
not going to put it on you you got to
decide but thank you for your service by
the way but you can do financial peace
university making 40 000 a year and you
didn't stop getting that disability when
you lost no i wasn't what no no no no i
i wasn't making anywhere near that at
that time
nowhere near you you got your disability
income didn't you
yeah yeah but
it was
yeah no no it wasn't but it wasn't but
it wasn't that high it wasn't all the
disability income has been adjusted
yes it has it has increased
in this last
uh
hold on i lied about that number a lot
but wait a minute
what's the real number i i think i'm 44.
so are you are you here's the question
that every person's got to ultimately
decide
you've got a 14 year old a 16 year old
and they're important they're your why
but
also you have to look in the mirror and
decide i'm ready to change my life
oh yeah i'm ready i'm ready like like
then your past doesn't matter
yeah
all you can control is tomorrow morning
that's it
yeah
and you've had some hard challenges and
some ugly challenges you've seen war
you've seen all kinds of mess
and here you are and what you get to
decide is what tomorrow's gonna look
like
are you ready to change your life
oh yeah most definitely are you certain
of it
oh most definitely it's gonna it's gonna
have to change the way you talk to
yourself the way you think about
yourself the way you champion yourself
in those kids
the way you look at them and say hey we
got free college in the state we're
gonna we're gonna run with it and you
can breathe the way you start saving
money follow the baby steps it's gonna
be a totally different way of talking to
darcy
are you ready of course i am you can't
say people like me
don't win you can't say that anymore
because people like you now win because
that's you are a different people
yeah
yeah that's what that decision does are
you ready i don't trust you yet i don't
either
i am ready i am ready are you going to
count the cost of what it's going to
cost you you may have to get new fringe
you may have to tell your kids hey you
all got to get jobs
you make 71 000 a year now and you're
broke
well no no no no no not now not now not
now i have i have almost 30 000 in the
bank right now now what's that do you
and how much debt do you have
and that i don't know the answer to i
just got how much debt i
don't i know really
i i what are you all on that car you
bought
oh you know what i don't i paid off my
car already i don't have any debt on
that student loans uh
no student loans credit cards
i don't have any credit cards medical uh
medical debt that's a different story i
have a son that's special needs
and uh that that is from that other than
and
i'm still fighting with the insurance on
that one but other than that what kind
of debt have you got
my house note okay other than those two
things what have you got
and um
i had a loan stupid me i had a loan and
i'm like at 18 on that and i'm thinking
about just level because i've been
doubling up on my house because i i was
like well let me go ahead before that
loan happened let me double up on my
house or whatever and that's what i've
been doing so darcy listen listen
you're creating chaos
and what you need is what you need is
peace
you're trying to double up over here not
pay over there call insurance company
over here then triple up over here and
go back and not pay that and it just
creates this chaos this frenzy
and what dave's trying to give you is
peace
yeah so here's what we're gonna do you
hold on kelly's going to pick up
i'm going to sign you up for a fresh
class of financial peace university i'm
going to pay for it as a part of a
ramsey plus membership and that's how
you access financial peace university
now
it also includes the every dollar
premium app
and darcy
this time i want you to follow orders
like you're in the military and bring
your boys along with you this time i
want you to do everything exactly
like we tell you to do it no
variance
i want you to stick with it exactly
because you never heard me one time back
when you went through a pu tell you to
pay double on your house while you're
sitting on a stupid 18 loan
that's so discombobulated kiddo
and you can do better than this um
even with all the different things you
got in your life even with the different
challenges
but you need a very very clear path
and a very clear line and you don't get
off the line
you stay right on the line one foot in
front of the other
follow the recipe exactly
and we'll make some great gumbo
but if you don't if you go make up your
own stuff don't expect it to turn out
because that's what happened between the
time you left financial peace university
the first time
and now
is you never once applied the exact
recipe and it would never have you
paying extra on your house would never
have you dealing with that you don't
know what's going on with these medical
bills you don't have a clear organized
precise plan
and that precision is where your piece
will come from it requires some extra
work
um and you kind of sweat and have a
little stress while you're doing it
but the end result is you are now on top
of the numbers managing them they're not
managing you and you get to choose your
heart from this point forward you want
to live in chaos and
payment to payment to payment to
or do you want to work really hard for a
couple of years and breathe and sleep
choose your heart that's the way it
works you can do it kiddo hold on kelly
will pick up